[Musique]
bhl
david koubbi bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle think you on aurait voulu
avoir votre
vision de la justice de la démocratie et
de la fère kerviel je vais mettre une
précaution oratoire spécialement
aujourd'hui parce que tu es mon avocat
va donc comme tu es mon avocat je ne
vais pas pouvoir te vous voyez
qu'est ce que tu veux je vais avoir du
mal aussi qu'est ce que tu peux me dire
sur la justice en france on en est où la
vue de chez moi vu de là où je me trouve
mais tu trouveras des gens quittent
expliqueront que tout ça est de la
foutaise
on est dans une situation qui est
particulièrement préoccupante parce que
la justice est à divers égards tenu tenu
comment par qui robert va se le dire
pendant une heure
j'imagine
tenue
et elle est totalement dysfonctionnelle
elle ne fonctionne pas alors non il faut
nuancer un peu le propos
un dossier de monsieur machin contre
madame truc tout va bien se passer et le
droit dira qui a raison et qui a tort
mais quand il ya des dossiers qui sont
dits signalé c'est avec un signalement
particulier et tu sais très bien quel
type de dossier je fais référence
c'est-à-dire quand tu as un candidat à
la présidentielle un ancien président de
la république un financier de haut vol
industriel un peu charte honte est une
institution bancaire par exemple
là il ya une sorte de
pacte de places qui se met en oeuvre qui
se met en route de manière tout à fait
silencieuse et chacun sait ce qu'il a à
faire pour planter le dossier c'est la
justice des copains ouais ouais c'est
comme ça que j'ai qualifié il n'ya pas
il n'ya pas très longtemps c'est une
justice entre potes c'est une justice
qui se passe dans le noir quelles sont
les conséquences pour le pékin lambda
le pékin lambda
lorsqu'il est pris dans cette nasse dans
cette voie non seulement ce filet
médiatico judiciaire
et qu'il importe qu il qu'il soit
condamné et bien il est au mépris des
droits de sa défense au mépris du droit
tout court
l'indépendance des juges mais n'est pas
du tout
opérationnel je vais dire je crois pas
tu sais sky qu'on puisse poser la
question de manière si général parce que
tu as toujours de très bonnes surprises
c'est ce qui fait que notamment moi je
continue de de faire ce travail tu as
toujours des résistants l'importance mot
résistant et il y en a chez les juges
qu'ils soient qu'ils appartiennent à
l'instruction ou au siège c'est-à-dire à
l'autorité de voix aux diverses
autorités qui existe dans l'ordre
judiciaire je sais pas si on ira là
dessus ou pas tu es tu venir à ce que tu
veux qu'on qu'on aborde mais
en gros pour pour essayer de résumer
dans ces dossiers il ya des réseaux qui
sont à l'oeuvre alors qu'elle lui qu'il
dise quel type de réseau je vais
t'expliquer ça alors tout de suite il
faut dire un mot parce que cette phrase
et je pense qu'on est ici typiquement
dans un endroit où ce propos ne choquera
pas m'aimer cette phrase quand elle est
émise quand elle est verbalisé tout de
suite tu as une espèce de levée de
boucliers ou on te dit à la théorie du
complot
non la relation des faits au sens
relater les faits au sens observer ce
qui se passe actuellement et le décrire
donc
ces réseaux ils sont de divers ordres
c'est à dire il ya des sortes de
fraternité il ya des sortes quand tu dis
fraternité tu parles de la
franc-maçonnerie notamment notamment
alors
j'ai pas c'est pas mon cheval de
bataille la france la franc maçonnerie
et puis en théorie quand je regarde
comment le comment le machin fonctionne
c'est plutôt joli tu vas mais on ne vit
pas dans la théorie on vit dans la
pratique et en ce qui me concerne alors
tu reçois des gens qui font tout un tas
de boulot différent en ce qui me
concerne dans la théorie judiciaire
voilà et donc quand dans un certain
nombre de dossiers tu constates que ton
adversaire tout comme le procureur
tout comme son avocat
peut-être maçon
ça ne signe pas qu'il y à une magouille
mais tu peux pas ne pas le voir donc ça
peut être ça ça peut être des copines
riz en tout genre il y à des clubs
déléguant alors nous on n'est pas sur ce
dossier là en tout cas on n'est pas dans
le temps des élégants on est on est dans
le camp d'eads et turbulent tu vois
nounou turbulon logement c'est comme ça
qui vous qualifie oui bien sûr parce
qu'ils sont dans une espèce de process
un peu de procéder un peu incantatoire
où à force de répéter la même connerie
200 fois sur cinq médias choisis ils se
mettent eux-mêmes à croire
aux salades qu'ils inventent tu vois
c'est ça qu'ils font ces mêmes et c'est
même comme ça qu'on arrive à à les
décrypter parce que le processus pour
pour décrypter c'est un processus qui
est très important parce qu'on est dans
une dynamique là dans ce type de dossier
je te parle notamment de la sphère dit
kerviel et autour d' évoquer un certain
nombre d'autres mais on est dans un
processus où pour que le message ne
passe pas il est important pour ces gens
et on met des noms sur les gens au
moment où tu le veux tout va bien parce
que je t'écoute mais je suis pas dans un
propos général tu vois on peut rentrer
dans le sujet on va le faire on n'est
pas les avocats de société générale par
exemple que jean veil jean reinhart tu
vois ce sont des ce sont des gens qui
fabriquent une espèce de vérité
médiatique
au terme de laquelle ils nous accusent
quasi systématiquement de ce qu'ils sont
a eu des exemples bas par exemple moi je
serais un avocat médiatique alors que
mon activité soit médiatique à divers
égards c'est le cas mais tu es bien
placé pour le savoir mais parce que les
médias s'intéressent à ça et qu ils nous
sollicitent et tu sais très bien pour me
connaître bien que je passe plus de
temps à refuser des interviews car en
faire quand on y va c'est que quelque
chose a déraillé là il renverse un peu
l'équation en disant
kerviel et koubbi font ça parce qu'ils
veulent se médiatiser mais nous on vend
pas des des tee-shirts on vend pas des
livres on fait la promotion de rien tu
comprends notre tête qu'il te dis ça
parce qu'ils ont l'impression que tu
souhaites retourner l'opinion publique
contre eux alors moi je ne souhaite pas
retourner l'opinion publique parce que
si je retournais l'opinion publique elle
serait dé facto contre nous parce que
l'opinion publique est déjà contre
contre eux
moi je ne suis pas là pour ça moi je
suis là pour te dire une chose qui est
très simple c'est que je ne ressens nul
besoin de les calomnier de les dix
femmes et de les dénigrer de les
ridiculiser puisqu'il nous suffit là où
nous en sommes rendus de les décrire
ainsi qu'ils sont qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait là sur ce dossier tu veux je
souhaite aussi qu'ils ont inventé une
fable qui a servi à renommer un certain
nombre de pertes financières comment ils
ont formulé colossal en disant que que
jérôme kerviel était un terroriste en
disant qu'il était en fuite en disant
que c'était un ancien membre des
services de contrôle en disant que
c'était un joueur en disant qu'il était
suicidaire en disant que c'est un
pervers manipulateur en faisant de moi
une sorte d'animateur télé raté ou un
acteur de série z qui ceux qui se
voyaient à hollywood ou
ou ailleurs
la réalité du sujet c'est pas ça là
c'est que jérôme kerviel a merdé dont
les proportions qu'on sait et qui
l'admet et qu'il admet depuis le premier
jour de la faire oui il a pris des
positions spéculatives qui sont en
volumétrie en nominal totalement hors
norme mais il trop les pincer hiérarchie
mais naturellement tu sais c'est un
c'est un milieu où quand beaucoup de
traders nous dit ça parce qu'on parle
avec beaucoup de gens du marché
financier on te dit ils vont une phrase
qui les fait marrer je comprends pas ce
qu elle est marrante qui et quand tu
tiens un bouc book de trading un
portefeuille de trading et que tu va
pisser ton supérieur hiérarchique vient
contrôler ce que tu as fait pour voir
tes pose tes positions spéculatives
donc si tu veux aller expliqué que
jérôme kerviel a fait tout cela
seul seul et sans que personne ne l'ait
vu ça ce sont des foutaises donc la
question après c'est quel intérêt et
cela sert que de que de tricoter de
telle foutaise alors il ya bien il n'est
bien quand même des alertes sur une
salle des marchés jérôme kerviel il n'a
pas pu quand même créé une salle de
marché virtuelle pour passer ses ordres
comment comment la société générale a
justifié le fait de ne pas voir les
choses ah non je nomme attention société
générale n'a rien à justifier parce que
c'est société générale et donc je vous
prierais de retirer cette question que
je trouve très insultant cette honorable
banques non société générale ne justifie
rien ses avocats ne justifie rien parce
que tu sais il y a deux codes pénaux il
ya le code pénal
pour les gens qui te regarde c'est à
dire les mister 2006 nobody donc là il
est épais il est technique il nécessite
de payer des avocats pour savoir comment
comment vous monter tout ça et puis il
ya un code pénal qui est beaucoup plus
fin qui est celui de la justice entre
entre potes
donc c'est chiant ce que je dis et je
je sais que ça plaît pas mais c'est
comme ça par exemple quand quelqu'un
pourrait m'expliquer pourquoi un
ministre chargé de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale chez intesa qui est
lui-même un évadé fiscal ne fait pas un
jour un jour de détention provisoire
quand on envoie en prison un citoyen
comme jérôme kerviel qui ne s'est pas
enrichi qui n'a pas tenté de le faire il
ne s'est pas enrichi parce qu'il a loupé
il s'est pas enrichi parce qu'il n'a pas
compté de le faire et qu'on l'envoie en
prison pour cinq ans dont trois ferme
alors il se trouve que nous avons obtenu
l' aménagement de sa peine au bout de
trois mois mais même trois mois mettre
un manteau du temps pire au moment où tu
rentres en prison tu sais pas que ça va
durer trois mois
comme com comment on va revenir sur
jérôme je voudrais je voudrais qu'on
aborde
l'aspect judiciaire comment comment le
fonctionnaire tu abordes comment ils se
comportent par rapport au dossier est ce
que c'est le fonctionnaire dévoué à
faire respecter la loi où tu sens que
il en a rien à faire il a reçu des
consignes ben là encore sky tu peux pas
poser l'équation comme ça parce qu'elle
est elle est trop
pardon mais elle elle est trop
manichéenne il n'y a pas un
fonctionnaire il y à une multitude de
fonctionnaires donc en gros pour
répondre un peu mainstream tout le haut
du panier est contre nous le gratin oui
bien sûr et puis en dessous les jeunes
résistants les plus petits tu vois
d'ailleurs ce sur la gueule desquels on
appuie
pour mettre en place des schémas qui
sont uniques qui ne respectent pas le
droit est bien de temps en temps
lagrasse fait que cela nous rallye la
grâce ou ou peut-être le fait qu'il soit
aussi perturbée par leurs propres
valeurs laurence la grâce de la grâce
mais c'est ça la grâce la grâce c'est
quand
moi qui suit ont subordonné j'entends un
ordre qui est illégal et que j'ai là
deux choix tu vois comme quand tu
arrives à l'orée d'un y soit tu pars à
gauche soit tu pars à droite mais ça ne
se rejoindra plus jamais et donc là il y
a des gens qui écrase le coup et qui
font ce qu'on leur demande de faire ceux
là sont promus ils sont choyés ils sont
chouchoutés
tout va bien et puis il y en ad'autres
s'appelle des lanceurs d'alerté est un
sujet que vous connaissez injection et
dans le monde est ce que est ce que dans
le dossier kerviel tu as tu eu des
lanceurs d'alert côté judiciaire bien
sûr qu'elles ont été comment ça c'est
formulé comment ça a été réfléchie ou
c'était simplement instinctif où
s'étaient alors je ne suis pas le mieux
placé parce que je ne suis pas moi
lanceur d'alert je suis le le défenseur
de jérôme kerviel son avocat mais
le commandant nathalie leroy qui est
l'officier de police judiciaire qui
appartient au corps de la brigade
financière la très prestigieuse brigade
financière château des rentiers
cette personne et la policière qui est
en charge de l'enquêté dès le dépôt de
plainte de société générale en janvier
2008 et donc elle va être la cheville
ouvrière de tout le dossier
donc tu vois comment ça se passe une
l'instance pénale tu as un dépôt de
plainte ou une auto saisine par le
ministère public c'est à dire le
procureur de la république en suite de
cela tu as une enquête préliminaire ou
une instruction ou les deux
chronologiquement et puis là tu as des
opérateurs police qui vont travailler en
aide du magistrat instructeur c'est à
dire du juge d'instruction qui en
l'occurrence c'était renault vendre une
bac et sur ces sujets je crois qu'il est
important de dire quels sont les noms
des gens qui ont été impliqués parce que
si je te demande qui a condamné 16 mecs
je ne sais pas me répondre non plus
d'ailleurs si je te demande qui a
condamné dreyfus on ne sait pas répondre
à ça parce qu'on dit c'est l'institution
ça
c'était une vision du judiciaire que je
qualifierais ce qui nous permet de à la
papa là maintenant il est important que
les actions de tel ou tel fonctionnaire
les engage
mais moi j'aime bien et tu sais par
exemple notre relation à nous deux est
basé là dessus tes mots tangage mémo
m'engage parole est une parole oui mais
c'est évident tu sais nous on est dans
le clan des bons coups mais moi j'ai
prêté un serment
je colle à mon serment je ne dis pas je
ne tangente pas et jérôme kerviel c'est
la même chose c'est je le dis souvent
marrant en corse avec lui non mais t'es
qu'un breton basque breton c'est pas
pareil si tu veut céder en tout cas lui
tu vois ça dévie pas ça recule pas ça
plie pas bon mais ces gens là
lanceur d' alerte ils sont face à des
choix qui sont des choix
très violent parce que tu as le choix
entre le confort de faire ce qu'on te
dit de faire il ya une espèce de confort
un peu paternaliste là dedans qui échut
ton supérieur je te demande de faire ça
une soumission consentie il est très
simple oui et puis tu sais ce que je
pense de ça je crois et puis il ya un
autre choix qui est
celui de rallier le camp de l'honneur
et c'est ce qu'a fait cette policière
c'est à dire que quand je rentrais dans
le dossier non pas en janvier 2009 quand
je m'occupais des deux des intérêts de
jérôme kerviel en droit de la presse et
uniquement en droit de la presse mais en
mars 2012 lorsque j'ai pris là la tête
de sa défense pénale côtés d'autres
avocats de mon cabinet comme tu sais
j'ai dit à jérôme on va commencer par
rencontrer toutes ses adversaires et il
a nommé sept flic nathalie leroy donc
moi je congèle dans ce dossier et je
voyais que je sais pas je te dire une
bêtise mais 90 à 95% des actes de la
procédure en enquête donc pendant
l'instruction et est siglé à son nom
elles faisaient les comprend des
confrontations du perquisition
elle signe les pv d'audition procès
verbaux d'audition tu vas voir nos
qu'elle était très très heureux sur le
sujet je suis allée la voir et je me
suis présenté il m'a reçue très
froidement c'est une personne qui est
intègre
ben écoute moi je n'en savais rien en
tout cas ce moment là mais je elle
postule est en tout cas tu vois et je
lui dis qu'est ce qui se passe si vous
êtes planté je te fait le trou et
compterait résumé hamadi je ne me tue
pas planter ma question se passe assez
qu'est ce qui se passe si vous êtes
planté alors je ne comprends pas la
question toi c'était très froid parce
que j'incarne et l'avocat de kerviel ou
s'était pas spécialement envie de me
voir qu'une autre je n'ai pas
spécialement envie de lavagna peut-être
pas le droit de croire oui et
complètement elle convoqué mon client
dans lequel des plaintes que nous
allions déposer donc je suis allée les
saluer
et
et puis elle m'a dit
m'a demandé de préciser ma question et
je lis est ce que vous ferez le job si
vous êtes planté ou est-ce que vous
allez couvrir votre erreur elle m'a
produits frais non travail et à partir
de là avec jérôme kerviel on a décidé de
drainer de nouveaux témoins vers elle le
questionnement qui étaient des
questionnements liés au dossier on a
décidé de l'envoyer s'avérait long parce
que on collaborait avec la brigade
financière puisque nous avions déposé
des plaintes et qu'elle enquêtait sur
les plantes que nous avions déposé fort
logiquement puisque là c'est tout le
premier volet du dossier et puis petit à
petit dans le procès verbaux d'audition
et dont le dirigeant ce dont elle est l
auteur
on se rendait compte que ça tournait tu
vois que sa vision était en train de
d'évoluer et donc j'ai pris le risque de
demander au doyen des juges
d'instruction roger le loire qui
instruit les trois plaintes enfin deux
des trois plaintes par donc nous avons
déposé contre société générale faux
usages et subordonnés escroquerie au
jugement subornation de témoin est
encore ailleurs
je fais cette demande d'actes auprès du
doyen des juges d'instruction lui des
moments de la recevoir par de la
convoquer pour l'auditionner sous
serment et ne lui pose un certain nombre
de questions 9 de mémoire et là une
audition procès verbal qu'elle a la
conviction d'avoir été manipulé par
société générale une édition procès
verbal que tout au début de la ferme
était convaincu convaincu de la
culpabilité de kerviel et qu'aujourd'hui
elle est convaincue de son innocence
elle me dit sur procès-verbal
qu'elle est convaincue que la hiérarchie
de jérôme kerviel étaient au courant de
ses actions mais tu vois ce n'est pas
neutre et là elle devient annonceurs d'
alerte et là elle fait oeuvre de courage
tu vois c'est des trucs on dit que tu me
s'est pas spécialement douillet mais
c'est des trucs à chiale de beauté
est-ce que tu as en face de quelqu'un
qui a été un ennemi objectif
donc toutes les diligences hervé a amené
le dossier là où sa vision la commande
est de l'amener là on est où là
maintenant elle avec une paix car disait
elle est envoyé à cayenne alors écoute
il ne me revient pas de répondre
précisément sur le sur le sujet parce
que ça touche
d'autres intérêts et je ne suis pas son
avocat
mais
je peux te dire qu'elle a été lâché par
sa hiérarchie
et je peux te dire également que elle
subit en tout cas je ne sais pas si elle
subit là mais elle a subi le traitement
que nos honorables institutions réserve
à l'accoutumée au lanceur d alerte et
c'est dans ce contexte là qu'elle a pris
la décision
d'aller parler avec son homologue au
parquet c'est à dire l'autorité de
poursuite la section financière du
parquet de paris qui est censé être
notre avocat à tous
dans ce dossier ce n'est pas comme ça
que ça s'est passé ils sont comportés
comme étant les avocats de la société
générale voilà l'avocat général qui
devient l'avocat général de la société
générale c'est des mots durs tu vois le
truc bah oui mais c'est des mots durs
mais que j'assumerai q c'est bien ça et
elle a enregistré la conversation
qu'elles sont venues et alors que sept
procureurs de la république parler en
toute liberté
alors que le commandant nathalie leroy
aucun moment de la lance de la piège en
posant des questions en disant que la
vub on est bien
cette procureur confirme ce que dit
cette policière c'est à dire que le
dossier a été entièrement manipulée elle
donne des noms elle donne des dates elle
implique des gens elle dit qu'elle a eu
à signer des choses qu'elle n'avait pas
la volonté de signer elle évoque des
pressions elle évoque des manipulations
tu vois donc on est dans un sujet qui
est
très aigu là c'est fonctionnement
institutionnel graphisme évidemment et
nathalie leroy commandant de police on
avait parlé à sa hiérarchie on avait
parlé au parquet a déposé je
l'expliquais devant le doyen des juges
d'instruction
a fait état de cela son ministère de
tutelle c'est à dire le ministère de
l'intérieur
et rien ne s'est passé à part le fait
qu'elle s'est fait brûler comme un
lanceur de l'ertt donc la halle après la
décision de m'adresser le contenu de ces
enregistrements en indiquant que j'en
était l'unique
dépositaire
l'unique détenteur en me disant qu'elle
avait tout tenté pour que la justice
passe sereinement et que ce n'est pas ça
qui se passait
et donc moi j'ai été confronté à ce
moment là un choix qui consistait soit
dans le fait de le dire d'un côté vous
avez enregistré à son insu procureur de
la république
je ne peux pas utiliser cet élément ou
notre choix ça me y donc je te parlais
était je suis en charge la défense de
jérôme kerviel je suis avocat à la cour
d'appel de paris j'ai prêté un serment
ce salon doit servir la défense on doit
percer la défense au dessus tout j'ai
pris le
l'option
d'utiliser cet enregistrement est de les
rendre publiques
donc il ya très peu du contenu des
enregistrements qui a été rendu public à
date parce que il y a une démarche
stratégique il faut pas se le cacher qui
parce qu'ils croisent une démarche
médiatique alors ça ça sur agace les
adversaires ce qu'ils disent oui alors
immédiate is et c'est évidemment qu'on
médiatise parce que leurs exploits
crapoteux ça se passe où
ça se passe pas à lui de vous
au vu et au su de tout le monde à répu
pas ça qui se passe ça se passe dans des
cabinets feutrés c'est dans le noir donc
notre boulot c'est de flasher suite on
fait développer les photos et on regarde
qui a la main dans la culotte de qui
tu vois c'est ça le sait ça le sujet et
tu sais qui m'a demandé ces
enregistrements certains n'ont personne
personne tellement les agissements
surtout personne
personne s'il ya une espèce de stratégie
de l'édredon tu vois pas ce que ce gros
machin comme et là dessus ces deux
couvercles une bonne procédure bâillon
donc voilà tout ça tout ça est assez
intéressant dans une vie d'homme et dans
une vie d'avocat c'est celle à faire de
ta vie
respire pas pour l'instant c'est la
faire de ta vie
toi en tant qu'homme avec tes valeurs
quand tu te retrouves face à la société
générale qui veut couler quelqu'un t'a
des valeurs tu te qualifies entre nous
d'anarchistes ça veut dire quoi
anarchiste pour toi
tu veux dire tu testes ma connaissance
sur ce qu'est l'anarchie ou tu veux dire
c'est à dire pour moi ouais écoute je me
suis qualifié il ya longtemps tu votes
banon pour qui je voterai pour qu'il
veux tu que je vote non non je ne vote
pas nom de ce que non je ne vote pas et
j'engage ce qui te regardent a cessé de
le faire
tu vois enfin ou alors à voter pour la
petite souris c'est à dire pour quelque
chose qui existe plus que l'équité
républicaine
je suis trop républicains pour ne pas
être anarchiste je sais pas si tu
comprends ça
j'ai une passion
lourdes
forte pour la république et ce qui en
est fait aujourd'hui
par
deux douzaines de connard
qu'ils se sont mis sur les fauteuils de
nos gouvernants me dégoûte ou plus haut
point au plus haut point et je les
fréquente beaucoup là encore
je ne souhaite pas que tu entendes dans
mon propos
que je fais une espèce de machin tous
pourris parce qu'il ya des politiques
comme mélenchon comme eva joly comme
georges fenech tu vois donc son insolent
ouais ouais que je que j'ai rencontré et
qui est qui et qui est un
vrai mec engagé il ya un gars lui qui
est un député socialiste marie noëlle
lienemann qui est sénateur socialiste
également donc tu vois tous ces gens là
et j'en oublie julien bayou alexis
corbière dont il ya des gens de gauche
chez les gens de droite
eric alauzet chez les ch et deux
écologistes etc qui sont des gens qui
ont une vraie passion pour le pays et
qui sont des gens dont l'intégrité ne me
questionne pas alors c'est pas parce que
je n'ai citer que ceux-là que
pardon par avance pour ce qu'ils
regarderaient ce que nous sommes en
train de faire et que j'ai oublié mais
ça ne veut pas dire que tout ce que je
n'ai pas cité ne le sont pas mais on est
dans un dispositif national là qui doit
préoccuper de gens qui nous regardent
parce que on est en train de l'or
raconter une espèce de fable un peu
lénifiantes tu vois un peu sortent
d'anesthésiant comme ça
où on en appelle à notre sursaut
républicain pour barrer la route à
marine le pen en 2017 pour tu vois mais
c'est quoi la république c'est avant
tout une justice indépendante
il n'ya il n'y a pas de socle plus
important pour la république que
l'indépendance de la justice et
aujourd'hui voici je viens à ton micro
c'est pour témoigner de ce que la
justice n'est pas indépendante
la justice est tenue par les hanches
ça va nous emmener où tout ça
[Musique]
les anars vise le chaos
tu sais ça évidemment alors je me dis ce
temps ci de ça parce que et dans le
terme même d'anarchie les opposants à
l'anarchie long connoté négativement
c'est l'anarchie non c'est pas ça enfin
selon la formule consacrée l'anarchie
c'est la plus haute expression de
l'ordre qui est qui fondait sur
l'autogestion sur le fait que je sais où
est ma liberté ou est ce qu'elle
commence parce qu'elle termine ce qu'est
le respect de l'autre quelle est ma
place dans une société etc et j'attends
de toi si on met dans ce schéma que tu
exactement le même type de
préoccupations donc ça va nous emmener
où je pense que
il y à un effondrement
qui arrivera et cet effondrement il sera
soit politiques soient économiques et je
n'arrive pas à pronostiquer lequel des 2
arrivera en premier mais quand tu va
regarder ce qui se passe
dans les dents les sur les places de
contestation que ce soit en france ou à
l'étranger évidemment je regarde
beaucoup ça pour le voyage à l'étranger
et je vais beaucoup grenouille et dans
des milieux qui sont des mieux ultra
contestataires je suis très à l'aise
aussi quand je déjeune et je dîne avec
des dirigeants du cac 40 parce que tu ta
dégâts bien partout je n'ai pas envie de
l'espèce de machin où on serait dans un
truc qu'on dirait sortez vos fourches
mettait des têtes au bout des piques etc
c'est pas ça mon propos mon propos c'est
qu'il faut arrêter de tourner gens pour
des cons
et le bout par lequel moi je le vois par
ma formation par mon exercice quotidien
c'est le droit
et je crois que le droit est une chose
qui est trop
mail pour qu'on puisse en faire
n'importe quoi comme comme comme
certains se sont arrogé le droit de le
faire dans ce dossier société générale
notamment on va revenir sur la société
générale la société générale quel touché
de l'argent public
pour se remettre à flot pendant la crise
des subprimes non il n'a pas touché elle
l'a détourné elle est l'auteur du plus
gros casse du siècle puisque les gens
qui te regarde là doivent savoir que 2,2
milliards d'euros c'est beaucoup
d'argent ça veut dire deux mille deux
cents millions d'euros ont été donnés à
la société générale par le ministre
christine lagarde sous l'ère sarkozy en
violation
du droit et que qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
violé au met
des règles tout à la fois fiscale
comptable ce que pourquoi la sphère dit
kerviel existe et qu'elle prospère dans
le sens de la doxa de la ligne du parti
c'est à dire le ligne de com de société
générale
relayé par l'ancien gouverneur la banque
de france par françois fillon à l'époque
je disais c'est agir est une grande
banque etc etc je ne parle pas que de
jour de droite ce que j'arrive sur la
mouche suite après et pour que tout cela
fonctionne il faudrait qu'il n'existe
pas de droit bancaire il faudrait qu'il
n'existe pas de droit commercial et
faudra qu'il n'existe pas
d'expertise-comptable comprends pas ce
que ou alors il faudrait qu'on nous
explique pourquoi société générale a
violé toutes à la fois ces corpus
juridique c'est à dire ça c'est champ du
droit mais
ils sont dans une dynamique où ils se
sont arrogé le droit de tous et
notamment de détourner cet argent qui
d'après la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état alors je pars faire chier avec
mais le conseil d'état c'est la plus
haute juridiction administrative
et elle pose que un principe aux termes
duquel quand une société subit une
fraude cette fraude
donne droit ouvre le droit à percevoir
un tiers du montant de la fraude
sur les finances publiques mais à deux
conditions qui sont qu' il ne doit pas y
avoir de connivence entre le fraudeur et
sa hiérarchie ou pas de complicité il ne
doit pas y avoir de défaillance des
systèmes de contrôle de l'entreprise qui
a subi cette faune hockey
or quand l'administration lagarde donne
cet argent public le 2 milliards de dont
je te parle un l'instruction impliquant
jérôme kerviel débute à peine donc que
savons-nous à l'époque d'éventuelles
complicités ou du degré de connaissance
de des dirigeants général la réponse est
claire c'est rien et de société générale
est condamné par l'ansa l'ancêtre de la
cpr c'est à dire la commission bancaire
à payer 4 millions d'euros au
précisément défaillances de ses systèmes
de contrôle dit autrement ça signifie
que si toi et moi nous sommes associés
et qu'on se fait frauder par des gens
qui travaillent chez nous parce qu'on
s'est distribué des gros dividendes et
qu'on n'a pas musclé nos services de
contrôle et bien l'état français dira
fort légitimement dans ce cas là les
garçons le financent pas un tiers du
montant de votre perte de l'argent qui a
été détourné ou peu importe et là en
dépit de ce que ces deux
conditions ne sont pas remplies ne sont
pas remplies eh bien l'état a tout de
même décidé de donner ces 2,2 milliards
d'euros sans dire évidemment c'est sorti
deux ans plus tard et lorsque tu
interroges
c'était qu'est la nsa 2008 2008 c'est
lorsque tu interroges
moscovici
la gauche est passée ils te répondent
secret fiscal lorsque tu interroges
sapin qui se met à se dandiner
tu vois ça dans
tu trouves ça sur le sur le net à
l'assemblée nationale
il ment de manière ouverte à la
représentation nationale en disant mais
que penseriez-vous de moi si je j'allais
chercher cet argent sans décision de
justice mais il en a une le laisser en
justice puisque la cour de cassation en
toute hypothèse est que les gens qui te
regardent soit d'accord avec ce que je
viens de lire ou pas on s'en fout parce
qu'en toute hypothèse la cour de
cassation a cassé la condamnation de
jérôme kerviel sur les dommages intérêts
donc aujourd'hui j'en car elle ne doit
plus 4 9 milliards d'euros à la société
générale donc là il y aurait dû y avoir
quelqu'un à la société générale qui
aurait dû rembourser cet argent là ça
toujours pas été remboursés mais non ça
n'a pas été remboursée parce que il n'en
est pas question et 2 ça n'est pas
demandée par les ministres successifs la
question qui se pose pour revenir sur
faut-il voter ou pas c'est comment
peut-on observer une similitude absolue
de positionnement entre un gouvernement
libéral de droite sarkozy sous sarkozy
et un gouvernement socialistes ou de
gauche souffland pas de différence entre
les deux administrations pas un demi
degré de différence sur le sujet sur la
protection des lanceurs d'alert non plus
écoute je parlais diane galut tout à
l'heure yann galut ce député et son
équipe font un boulot sublime et je
regarde ça de très près à l'assemblée
nationale pour essayer d'obtenir un
statut pour les lanceurs de l'ertt mais
tu comprends bien
que ça c'est un
sujet qui est très délicat parce que
quand les lanceurs d'alerté seront
protégés la place le marché financier
l'industrie française européenne
mondiale etc
sera mise en brèche sera battu en brèche
sera mise en danger donc on est sur un
sujet où des gens de bonne volonté ce
que je viens de citer font tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour ériger un statut
pour fabriquer un statut pour s'élancer
en alerte et puis d'autres en face au
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour que ça ne
devienne pas
le peuple le peuple français si on peut
résumer la population française au
peuple français le peuple français n'est
pas conscient de ça
est-ce que tu as une idée pour s'il leur
demandez pas de se soulever mais de ceux
se saisir de ces problèmes
écoute moi ce n'est pas mon travail
d'avoir deux de faire des propositions
politiques mais j'ai à titre personnel
en tant que citoyen français dieu sait
que je suis attachée à cette citoyenneté
à ce pays qui est le nôtre
j'ai tout un tas d'idées mais qui seront
sans doute jugée trop radicale aller
mais coûte par exemple moi je ne je ne
conçois pas que nomme aucune femme
politique qui a été pris la main dans le
sac et qu'ils soient condamnés pour des
détournements de fonds publics puis se
remontrer sa gueule en politique
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie je vais tuer
pour le fait que les élus ne doivent pas
avoir de casier judiciaire ah oui et
puis je suis surtout pour le fait que
lorsque un homme politique tapez notre
caisse commune je suis pour que le
peuple lui prennent tous à hauteur de ce
qu'il a tapé ou à hauteur de 2 de toutes
les sommes qu'il aura perçu depuis qu'il
fait de la politique parce que toutes
ces sommes leur auront fabriqué en
chemin vers cette malhonnêteté et le
pays au plan économique ne peut pas
supporter de tels détournements ça n'est
pas possible on n'est pas avec 2 % de
chômage avec une croissance
totalement exponentielle on n'est pas
rendu là on a des problèmes de
d'incarcération on a des problèmes de
réinsertion on a des problèmes à
l'éduquer nationale parce que tu as tu
as tu avais tu as les gamins qui
arrivent en sixième sans savoir lire et
écrire on a des problèmes dans les
quartiers on a des problèmes de santé
publique tu vois donc on est parent hier
écoute
poudrière je ne sais pas mais moi je ne
vois pas aujourd'hui comment un tel
schéma peut continuer à perdurer aussi
souverainement que ce qu'il perdure et
quand il y avait trois chaînes de
télévision et les journaux du matin à
quelques heures du soir et je pense que
les réseaux sociaux
sont à regarder comme l'étaient les
messagers du pont neuf pendant la
révolution française parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est et
ça c'est important pour pour les gens
qui soutiennent des positions telles que
tel que telles que les nôtres et tu sais
ma proximité avec
avec ses milieux contestataires quand
nous défendons des hackers des anonymous
décrypte bernard schiste mais bon voilà
on ne fait pas que ça on a aussi un
travail d'avocat d'affaires parce qu'il
faut que tout ça serait équilibre et que
c'est ça que j'étais avant de
que ces gens là face de moi un avocat
militant tu vois un quasi avocat
guévariste
un statut qui m'ennuie pas rien tut tut
comment de fermer sa caisse qui t'anime
toi en tant qu'homme qu'est ce qui te
fait vivre qu'est ce qui te fait
souffler qu'est ce qui te fait te
reposer quand tu a plaidé en face d'eux
les pierres menteur qui fait quoi pour
survivre
cet ultra stimulation de ton cerveau tu
fais quoi pour tiger est d'abord c'est
pas si dur que ça dit survivre parce que
dans ce champ professionnel ce qui
m'anime c'est je te le dis le serment
que j'ai prêté je pense que les trains
sacrifierait ta vie pour concernant
elle est compliquée ta question mais
[Musique]
ce imagine toi demain
je suis ton adversaire je te pose un
milliard d'euros sur la table je dis bon
maintenant ça suffit non mais où est
donc ça ça revient à ça revient à être à
vendre on n'est pas à vendre le jeu quoi
qu'il arrive on dit d'où le nom d'alain
prix non non il n'y a pas de prix comme
ça société générale connaît très bien
les règles du jeu puisque ils ont fait
la connerie de dire publiquement vous
aurez si les acheter c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche ils ont dit publiquement
violent
les règles déontologiques qui régissent
la profession d'avocat qu'ils allaient
négocier avec les avocats de kerviel
donc ça ça y est c'est public les
négociations entre avocats sont en
théorie confidentiel nous nos conditions
pour s'arrêter elles sont très simples
on s'excuse publiquement et de ils
dédommagent kerviel il était moins une
lanceurs d'alerté dont ils ont pourri la
vie mais ça s'arrêtera pour eux et on
expliquera à partir de ce moment là que
c'est une s'agit nullement vertueuse
mais avant ça elle ne peut pas être vues
comme étant une banque vertueuse
donc tu vois dans ce contexte c'est pas
très compliqué pour moi de me détendre
parce que je suis pas très tendu parce
que ce qui nous anime au sein du cabinet
28 octobre qui le cabinet à laquelle
auquel pardon j'ai la chance
d'appartenir pourquoi 28 octobre
pour tout un tas de réseau dans laquelle
on va pas entrer là mais en tout cas
principalement pour que tu poses la
question et tu vois ça ça fonctionne
mais blague à part
la justice étant sous jacent qui est
très très prégnant chez très présent et
la beauté du combat donc tout ça ça nous
fatigue pas parce qu'on a annoncé câble
est alors ouvert donc s'il devait y
avoir des menaces il devait y avoir des
pressions s'il devait y avoir des choses
pour essayer de nous impressionner un
peu comme nous ne sommes pas les avocats
particulièrement douillet ça nous
donnerait plus d'essence que deux en
fait dans ces dossiers il faut enlever
la trouille de l'équation sinon il faut
faire mais tu les fais tu t'es fait
cogner carrément je me suis fait
agresser mais on n'a pas d'élément qui
permette de dire si ça en lien ou pas
donc ça n'est pas en lien parce que il
faut pas fantasmer les choses je fais
agresser il ya autant mais tout ça est
désormais derrière et dans ma vie à moi
dans ma vie d'homme je vois mes amis
j'ai la chance d'être dans vend super
projet avec un homme auquel je veux
rendre hommage qui s'appelle david
chatelus ce qui amenuise y ait de génie
on dessine des meubles ensemble je suis
allé le voir à quel dessein que j'avais
envie de décliner moi je n'avais pas la
compétence pour faire ça à mon grand
père paternel était ébéniste d'art donc
tu vois c'est quelque chose avec quoi je
renoue et donc on s'associe tous les
deux sur ce projet pour fabriquer des
meubles parce que si tu veux quand tu
quand tu brasses les
des chiffres comme ça dans les dossiers
etc il faut faire attention de ne pas se
décaler du réel trop tu penses que les
hommes politiques ce oui oui oui mais
mais mais aussi un certain nombre
d'avocats tu vois le dossier société
générale que tu es ok au début
sa cause en milliards comment tu sais
plus de quoi tu parles
tu vois moi quand je suis entré dans ce
dossier je donne bien alors attends
merde comment ces 10 milliards comment
comment s'écrit un milliard c'est quoi
c'est combien de millions c'est que ma
voiture parce que pas des choses que tu
que tu mouvement quotidiennement et donc
chaud que c'est bien d'aller se planquer
au faubourg là de temps en temps dans
son atelier pour pour dessiner les trucs
discuter avec lui couper des machins vis
et des bidules coller des trucs tu vois
donc chasser c'est une activité qui je
pense qu'en vieillissant j'aurai besoin
de vendre quelque chose c'est à dire de
d'avoir un rapport à l'argent qui est
moi je fabriquais ça et toi ça te plaît
alors donne moi de l'argent pour que je
te donne mon machin parce que là on est
dans une espèce de nous en tout cas que
bien qu'on fait dans une espèce
d'économies qui est totalement
immatériel nom n'est pas virtuel parce
qu'on vend du temps mais voilà donc
enfin notre cabinet structuré il ya plus
d'une vingtaine d'avocats dedans tout le
monde traite des dossiers enfin tout est
bien mais
je pense que quand tout sera fini
et quand j'aurai envie de passer à autre
chose je resterai avocat pour traiter
quelques dossiers par an et que j'aurai
envie de fabriquer des bidules tu vois
jérôme et dans quel état dans la douche
et 450 me dûment élu à faire un jugement
aux prud'hommes pour 450 millions avec
80 millions payables de suite que
société générale fera tout pour ne pas
payer en expliquant médiatiquement que
depuis d'argent en expliquant
médiatiquement que
jérôme kerviel leurs doigts 4,9
milliards d'euros ce qui est faux
puisque entre quand je te le dis il ya
cinq minutes est maintenant ça de cette
somme demeure cassé par la cour de
cassation mais ils sont dans un degré de
contrariétés qui se mesure quand tu
regardes les interviews de leurs avocats
sur les plateaux
moi j'ai l'impression de voir une espèce
de stratégie de canard sans tête tu vois
où tu vois mon confrère jean veil partir
sur les plateaux pour expliquer aux
journalistes de bfm notamment que toutes
nos procédures vont être classés sans
suite qu'il y aura des nouveaux lieux
que société générale va triompher il te
dit ça c'est dans six mois ça c'est dont
deux enfants
cet homme semble peiner à comprendre que
ce qui lui est reproché c'est très
précisément ce à la justice n'est pas
une institution tu peux tenir par la
main ni quand tu as un avocat ni quand
tu es à un politique sinon ce n'est plus
la justice est autre chose voilà dans
lequel était à jérôme il est très
sincèrement il est fatigué tout ça
e
parce que c'est intense et huit ans de
combat il a fait de la toule il a été
voir le peuple ils étaient marché
voir le saint père est rentier rentrée
de rome à pied
ces têtes c'était une
c'était un épisode qui était
fantastique pour lui il dit que c'était
cette marche était
au rendez plus des plus des meilleurs
moments de sa vie et je le crois parce
qu'il était tout seul il était tu vois
il était dans une chose que je peux dire
que quand tu es tout seul c'est le maire
de nantes avis que je veux dire c'est
que il a eu il a eu un temps
introspectif qui lui a permis de se
retrouver de ce parce que tu vas fins
est décédé ce sont des parcours des
destins
qui ressemble pas des lessiveuses quand
même
tu vois à partir du monde ça claque en
janvier 2008 jusqu'à maintenant
il ya eu un certain nombre d'instances
il ya eu un certain nombre de
contrariété il ya eu un certain nombre
d'espoirs parfois déçu toi
des convocations il ya eu des dons
classe il sert et se voit sur son visage
quand on le voit apparaître qu'il ait
marqué ce qu'ils ne seraient pas sky est
ce qu'ils ont cherché à le tuer
au sens le tuer comme on pourrait
l'admettre n'ont évidemment pas
est ce que dans l'or c'est une procédure
bâillon c est ce que dans leur bande y
en a qui est suffisamment intelligent
pour se dire que n'importe qui soumis à
ce à quoi ils ont soumis pourrait
décider de se suicider
souhaite pas insulter leur intelligence
donc je te répondrais qu'il y en a
plusieurs qui ont pu faire ce calcul la
wii vient de se dire comment tu tiens
quand tu es jérôme kerviel est là il est
passé d'un schéma de survie un schéma de
vie parce qu'aujourd'hui la trouverez
une série qui fait qu elle en ce moment
mais il est pas d insérer il n'est pas
question pour lui de se réinsérer il
n'est pas un délinquant il est il est un
homme honorable il est un homme honnête
c'est pas ce n'est pas nous les
délinquants c'est pas nous les
malhonnêtes c'est pas nous c'est vinifie
quoi lancement
il travaille beaucoup sur le dossier il
a monté une boîte avec l'un de ses amis
un de ses proches dont qu'il lance une
activité
et puis il est illettré tenue dans ce
combat dans lequel
il n'a pas été invité qui est un combat
qu'on lui a imposée ils avaient le choix
entre céder et combattre et
ce genre de bestioles ça cette part ils
évoquèrent bon le pain donnant lui lui
lui tel qu'il est foutu il cède pas ça
rien à voir avec moi je suis breton guy
breton mais qu'est ce qui reste encore
comme procès de la société générale
15 16 17 juin mercredi jeudi vendredi
nous sommes à cour d'appel de versailles
pour
évalués d'après ce que nous dit la cour
de cassation les fautes de société
générale pour savoir si kerviel doit
quelque chose à la générale ou pas
donc
si nous y allons nous y allons
sereinement mais ça c'est là que du
dossier initial de 2008 ils restent les
trois plainte que nous avons déposée
contre cette très honorable la banque d
plainte pour faux usage de faux et
escroquerie au jugement et subornation
de témoins
qui sont en cours d'instruction au pôle
financier de paris il reste l'appel
puisqu'il paraît que société générale a
envie de rejouer un round sur le
prud'homme les prud'hommes nous parfait
nous leurs jours
et puis il reste les procédures qui
émaneront des nouveaux éléments
dont nous disposons et que nous n'avons
pas encore exploités ni pleinement
exploités ni exploité du tout d'ailleurs
et qui la montre dans une granularité
beaucoup plus fine qui a tenu la main de
qui à quelles fins à quelle date et donc
on arrive dans une partie qui va être
nécessairement violente
ça sera brutal
parce que ce type d'institution se
défend
son loi de tenter de le faire mais moi
je ne vois plus aucune fin de l'histoire
ou jérôme kerviel perd là où nous en
sommes rendus avec ce dont nous
disposons pas ce que nous dénonçons un
procès qui a été manipulée
un procès qui a été truqué c'est pour
cela fait des années qu'on vous dit ça
et ça fait des années que personne ne me
convoque mois avocat auxiliaires de
justice en disant bon écoutez vous êtes
en train de dire des choses qui sont
graves il faut s'arrêter parce que etc
on ne me dit pas non plus montré
nouveaux éléments
on est dans une espèce de machin ou
savoir tourner la tête oui voilà c'est
ça et nous notre boulot c'est de prendre
cette tête et de la remettre dans l'axé
parce qu'il ya un sujet qui est là que
nous avons posées là ça fait des mois
que nous travaillons sur la manière dont
cette mascarade a été fabriquée qu'en tu
entend des phrases comme un
c'est délicat de rentrer dans les
détails là mais quand tu entends des
phrases comme
vous n'arriverez à rien
parce que tout le monde a été prévenu ça
t'évoque ça t'évoque quoi ça t'évoque un
combat qui s'annonce de manière loyale
donc tu vois donc
aujourd'hui on a des professionnels de
la justice qui nous ont rallié je te
renvoie une tribune très très émouvante
pour l'avocat que je suis qui s'appelle
pour l'honneur de la justice il faut
rejugé kerviel qui a écrit sale le
premier avocat général près la cour de
cassation qui est un homme qui s'appelle
yves charpenel donc je te demande de
mesurer le courage pour prendre une
telle position il emmène avec lui jean
de maillard qui est vice-président
tribunal de grande instance il amène
hélène franco et georges fenech
magistrate ancien
juge d'instruction quand tu vas donc
l'un des magistrats ici qui disent si la
justice s'est trompée c'est qu'elle a
été trompée et c'est bien ce dont on
parle et que tu le regardes
avec mes lunettes d'avocats ou avec tes
lunettes de citoyens ou le mène
d'ailleurs puisque nous partageons le
men est souvent et tu ne peux pas
admettre de mon point de vue que la
justice soit tenue ainsi qu'à l'aller
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
admissible et tu ça qu'on sait qu'on a
raison ce que je te disais parce que
personne ne nous a rien demandé parce
que les accusations que nous portons
sont des appuis des accusations qui sont
sourdes qui sont graves
tu te figure bien que si nous avions
tort si nous étions là pour vendre des
t-shirts marqués fait justice ou je sais
pas quoi si c'était ça notre business on
nous aurait tapé sur le dessus du crâne
en nous disant qu'est ce que vous
racontez vous êtes condamné vous êtes
poursuivi vous êtes suspendu en tant
qu'avocat vous à 4 bonestève où il se
passe rien alors tu as des journalistes
d'investigation comme denis robert com
martine orange mediapart les
journalistes comme vincent vantighem
comme nicolas cori quête au jour tu as
des gens qui ont fait ce travail là
d'aller regarder très précisément ce qui
se passe donc ça sort ça fait un boom
médiatique et puis ça redescend ça se
délite parce qu'il ya le boom médiatique
d'après donc quand tu me demandais tout
à l'heure qu'est ce que nous pourrions
faire au plan collectif par exemple
fabriqué à un endroit qui peut être
virtuel qui peut être numérique
qui est un endroit où nous suivrions
collectivement tant que citoyen un peu
comme des vigies citoyenne
qu'advient-il de talent ministre qui est
pris dans l affaire
parce que mon approche ce n'est pas de
se dire je me réjouis que tel ou tel
ministre soit la une des journaux que
son nom soit saloper
qu'il soit 1 femme est partout et
conduisant le voleur le menteur le
manipulateur le celui qui a détourné etc
et puis après il se passe rien pas ça le
sujet moi je préférerais plus de réserve
dans la phase du boom tu vois
lorsque lorsque je travaillais par
exemple contre
dominique strauss kahn
en 2011 la fameuse affaire affaire banon
oui
j'étais moi gêné par tout ce qui était
écrit elle dit sur strauss kahn qui
allait au-delà
de sa responsabilité ou de son innocence
pénale
moi je ne suis pas là pour fabriquer des
al ahly des lynchages c'est pas ça mais
en revanche un peu de suivi
sur le cas de telle ou telle qui aura
contribué à manipuler la justice je sors
de l'exemple que je vais évoquer à
l'instant mais un peu de suivi pour
répondre à ta question qu'est-ce qu'on
fait nouveau plan collectif citoyen
français ça ne serait pas complètement
inepte parce que tu vois on n'est pas
dans un schéma aujourd'hui le politique
contractuelle on n'est pas dans un
schéma où si tu te présentes à vos votes
et que tu l'obtiens et que tu es élu je
peux te demander des comptes donc
l'institution se protègent les
institutions politiques se protègent de
salle en disant si la sanction de la
presse elle vote d'après mais ça veut
dire que tu as un blanc semble pendant
un quinquennat pendant cinq ans ça ça
marche pas moi j'aimerais bien pour
aller voter pour la première fois de ma
vie ce qu'il faudrait c'est qu'on me
dise si toi tu te présentes et que tu es
lui tu es engagé
parce que tu as présenté parce que tu as
promis et si tu n'y arrives pas bah ça
nous va bien au plan collectif que tu
dégages t'as qu'à aller faire des
implants capillaires comme tu faisais
avant tu vois on talata car autour de
faire l'avocat utaka allait s'occuper
d'autre chose que de la chose publique
le bien public l'intérêt général qu'est
ce que tu penses de l'erika qui a été
interné d'office
écoute je je je ne connais pas le
dossier donc c'est compliqué pour un
avocat de alors évidemment si ce que je
lui est exactement ce qui s'est passé ça
ressemble à une petite carambouille
médiocre des gens qu'il a dû en merdé
je suis si ce que j'ai lu est fondée je
trouve que l'on vient nous emmerder de
plus en plus près
les avocats tu vois alors non pas qu'on
ait besoin parce que nos activités
seraient tellement secret totalement
délicate d'avoir des passe droits c'est
ça que je dis mais les droits de la
défense ça suppose
que les avocats ne soit pas museler un
suppose que les avocats ne soit pas
emmerdé dans leur quotidien et j'ai été
assez préoccupés tu vois par exemple
s'agissant des écoutes de sarkozy et de
son avocat je trouve
particulièrement inadmissible que la
conversation que peut avoir un avocat
avec son client puisse être entendu
qu'est ce que tu penses de l'état
d'urgence c'est que la meca l'état
d'urgence oui quel état d'urgence la
planète allure jour ce
pardon ne convenait pas l'état d'urgence
dix mois mais pourquoi il ya pas un état
d'urgence mais parce que quand tu as
quand tu as un ancien président de la
république
un ancien premier ministre un président
de la république en fonction un premier
ministre en fonction qui t'explique que
tu es robert que ton pays est en guerre
est-ce que tu as le droit en tant que
citoyen de constater que tu es protéger
oui tu as eu droit c'est un droit
fondamental
c'est quoi la protection aujourd'hui
c'est quand tu rentres dans un centre
commercial une sécurité privée qui te
dit ouvrez votre sac tu fais comme ça et
puis tu planque ce que tu veux dessous
je veux dire si on est en guerre alors
il faut que nous soyons armés
alors pas toi à moi n'importe qui mais
les réservistes les flics en civil les
gendarmes en civil tu vois
le bataclan
qui a été un carnage absolu
ça ça existe parce que personne n'était
armé
personne parmi les gens qui te regarde
là ne vont croire que cette menace là
est arrivé
du jour au lendemain alors dit
non mais mais mais mais intérêts soit
notre pays il ya eu meira m'aimera
c'était pas grave c'était des enfants
juifs
et puis c'était des militaires alors tu
vois c'est ni toi ni moi c'est des juifs
enfants et des militaires ensuite il ya
eu charlie c'est ni toi ni moi ces
journalistes c'est les journalistes la
merde des terrasses de café des
terrasses de confères de concerts doc la
faim et des salles de concerts donc là
ça peut être toi et moi mais cette
utilisation politique qui a été faite de
tous ces attentats je voulais qu une
utilisation politique est bien
évidemment mais bien évidemment ça n'est
rien d'autre qu'une utilisation
politique c'est à dire que fermin de
découvrir que cette menace existe et je
rentre pas dans font de cette menace
parce que je suis pas compétent pour le
pour le faire j'ai une vision kennedy y
ont strictement française je sais pas
comment je réagirais si j'étais libyen
syrien
du d'autres confessions de la mienne
j'en sais rien donc je vais pas rentrer
là-dedans qu'à une confession on en
reparlera après continue non j'ai une
religion naissance mais je n'ai pas de
confession mais je répondrai à tes
questions évidemment mais donc je sais
pas comment je réagirais si je voyais
les choses de manière un peu excentré
mais pour autant
nous faire croire que tout ça a bien la
manon comme ça mais ça prend pour des
cons elle secret des correspondances
l'état d'urgence était avocate et mon
avocat
mon téléphone est écoutée on n'a plus de
secret des correspondances c'est ça je
peux plus parler tranquillement mon
avocat non tu peux pas
donc tu peux pas parler tranquillement à
ton avocat et es tu ne peux pas être
défendue
avec les droits de la défense qui te
sont qui te sont alloués par le petit
livre rouge qui s'appelle le code pénal
tout ça n'est pas appliqué face à des
pans de la connerie tu feras si c'est
une connerie qui gênent personne bah oui
tout se passera bien si c'est une
connerie qui gênent l'elysée ça va être
plus compliqué pour toi
donc en fait si tu n'es pas un cas
d'anomalie là tu oublieras
jérôme kerviel c'est une anomalie
sont comprendre ça
à que n'importe qui ne supporte pas ce
qu'il a traversé comme il a été capable
de le supporter c'est un fantôme à
l'heure actuelle non pas du tout il n'a
jamais été aussi vivant il est il est
dans un état que que je trouve
globalement préoccupants d'une copine ce
pas des questions réponses c'est
préoccupant pourquoi son état
parce qu'il est soumis à rude épreuve
parce que moi je sais pas ce que ça fait
se lever tous les matins pendant huit
ans et que ton nom de famille ton nom
patronymique le nom de ton père le long
de la ligne et l'on détient soit krainer
dans la boue par par quatre godard qui
sont là pour pour servir d'autres
intérêts que
commence à prendre d'avocat qui sert ce
type d'intérêt tout s'est
passé ton millions d'euros en millions
d'euros bien sûr pour toute la procédure
ou en plusieurs millions d'euros
combien tu prends toi bats 0
je prendrai un pourcentage de ce que
nous gagnerons la fin
c'est un vrai toi tu vas chercher en bas
âge et a dit j'ai prêté serment et
enfin moi je suis devenu avocat pour
yahia là tout ce qui fait que j'ai eu
envie d'être un c'est pourquoi moi je
t'ai pris comme avocat parce qu'un jour
je t'ai appelé et il m'a dit si tu
arrive quoi que ce soit je brûlerai tout
pour te défendre
oui parce que parce que je sais les
intérêts que tu que tu défends et que
ses intérêts font écho
aux intérêts que je défends
si tu avais un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
soulevez vous soulevez vous ouais
comment
avec du talent avec du respect avec de
l'inventivité mais soulevez-vous est
resté et arrêter de rester assis sur vos
culs parce que ça va pas bien se passer
tu sais j'ai croisé un
gta j'étais à l'elysée il ya quelques
temps de cela j'ai croisé un très haut
conseiller
quelqu'un qui durent dans le temps
ils ont discuté
à une autre occasion
et il me disait je viens de donner pour
conseils à des étudiants de faire la
révolution
est ce que tu te rends compte de la
farce
et que tu as des gens à l'elysée je te
parle d'autres gens parce que je
grenouille beaucoup dans ces milieux
politiques parce que notre stratégie
dans le dossier société générale s'est
arrêtée d'alerter l'opinion j'assume ça
ça a était d'alerter le politique
je fais pas croire que je vais m'écarter
là ou là tu as bien vu qu'on est
très en retrait par rapport aux risques
de manipulation de reprise il ya
toujours vous allez vous faire c'est
quoi le terme vous allez vous faire
à part prendre
quiconque dit on récupère et récupérer
le risque de mercy le risque de
récupération tu vois bien qu'on ait
récupéré par personne on est capable
d'aller avec jérôme kerviel à la fête de
l'humanité a invité par jean luc
mélenchon on a des critiques de certains
caciques du parti socialiste et ses cinq
ans on leur répondait mais n'ayez pas
peur ce sont des gens de gauche
tu vois on a dit à hollande à vals
n'ayez pas peur du front de gauche
hollande il est toujours à gauche mais
non mais non il n'est pas à gauche et là
la mise et le volant mais j'en pense
rien je pense que je suis navré je pense
que quand on est le premier magistrat de
france et quand on a en main ce qu'il a
en main sur le dysfonctionnement de cet
appareil qui est un appareil noble à
dire que la justice c'est le truc qui
fait que je peux pas me comporter avec
toi comme j'ai envie de me comporter si
je suis dans un jour où je dévisse c'est
le truc qui fait que tu peux pas me tuer
que tu peux pas me violer que tu peux
pas me voler que tu peux pas te
comporter nous donc c'est quelque chose
qui est important dans un dispositif
démocratique et quand on sait ce qu'il a
en main sur ce dossier un certain nombre
d'autres et quand on voit l'inertie
qui est attachée à l'une quelconque de
ses actions mais c'est à vomir
c'est à vomir c'est pour ça qu'à la
question en écho à la question
est-ce que tu votes qu'est ce que tu
veux que je te répondent pour qui je
vais voter
moi je n'ai pas envie de voter pour des
espèces de clan
tu vois qu'ils vous font semble qu'ils
s'envoient des sms et puis qui font
semblant de s'écharper pour faire de la
politique interne highmount
pour les cons du peuple
c'est une caste mais ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'une caste qu'est ce que tu
crois
ça sort de l'ena un jour on se dira
peut-être collectivement que pour fermer
les n'a
donc si on ferme pas les là on a
peut-être le droit de tout conseiller
politique mais pas de se soumettre aux
mandats
mais tu te rends compte des réseaux que
sa fabrique l'ena enfin c'est des choses
où on ne se tue pas entre nous quand on
a une marque
donc évidemment que c'est une caste ça
n'est rien autre d'une caste
enfin moi je dis ça comme des gangs en
fait un pour tout te dire je vais un peu
au delà et je suis pas en train de me
laisser emporter par
le fait que nous nous connaissions le
fait qu'on soit dans un endroit agréable
où je suis tout à fait consciente de ce
film est que ceux de vos interviews donc
je suis pas dans une espèce
d'emballement
et ça quand tu es dans un média
classique c'est d'ailleurs ce qui m'a
conduit à accepter son invitation je te
remercie pour ça mais quand tu es dans
un média classique et que tu pente
d'évoquer ces sujets on te dit oui oui
d'accord
pas d'accord
justement on en parle parce que c'est
pas d'accord c'est tout seul d'accord tu
comprends
qu'est-ce que
et après qu'est ce qu'on fait après si
on arrivait un petit peu a récupéré un
système judiciaire la justice
si athéna rend la justice avec mais tu
sais il ya un programme politique qui
est tout à fait révolutionnaire
et qui à notre portée
je te dis que c'est révolutionnaire
parce que ça n'a jamais été fait c'est
application de la loi aux banques
application de la loi à la finance
l'application de la loi à tous
ce qu à l'assemblée nationale quand tu
vois qu'il ya des débats au taux d'il
faut légiférer là dessus alors c'est
l'état d'urgence alors en congrès aurait
eu surtout ça
on a besoin de rien on a des lois qui
fonctionne très très bien on a un
système judiciaire qui est croit le bien
très très très performant
mais encore faut-il appliquer la loi à
tous parce que si c'est à quelques uns
et pas à d'autres
c'est plus la loi c'est autre chose
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu as des questions à nous
poser à vous ouais plein en retard bah
oui plein au rcam évidemment mais mais
tu vois je pense pour répondre à ta
question qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est
ce qu'il ya après etc je pense que
chacun d'entre nous se doit avec les
moyens qu'ils allaient petit talent
qu'il a les idées qu'il a essayé de
faire avancer lâchés en train de bosser
avec avec une humoriste qui s'appelle
les lacs et lyon on a on a travaillé
ensemble sur un spectacle politique qui
s'appelle les condescendant qui joue
au théâtre en ce moment et on
explique un peu aux gens de manière je
coécris ça avec est là et
on a décidé que je mettais ce spectacle
en scène bon la mise en scène est une
vaste arnaque parce qu'en fait
c'est une humoriste qui se croient ils
se pensent de droite et qui est tout à
fait incontrôlable donc elle bouge comme
elle veut sur scène tout ça très marrant
mais bon je suis censé être 45000 ma
chose que je n'avais jamais fait mais
c'est c'est chouette de voir tu vois le
fonctionnement de ces gens et l'idée moi
quand je vais dans un truc comme ça
c'est pour me dire ben ce que j'arrive
pas à faire quand je suis dans un
prétoire ce que je n'arrive pas à faire
quand je suis en interview au grand
journal où dans un jt ou sur bfm sur i
télé bougez pas quoi ce que je n'arrive
pas à faire part une tribune en une de
l'humain ou ou une interview dans
médiapart touchez pas quoi
peut-être que je vais arriver à le faire
un peu différemment
s'essayant comme ça l'humour donc on
passe ses messages comme ça ça ça c'est
une vision très douce parce que moi je
fais ça pour détendre et que ma part de
combat je pense que je la porte tu vois
j'ai pas besoin d'aller m'engager dans
autre chose pour me donner de
l'adrénaline on est bien on y voit dans
un abîme l'a déjà mais mais mais je
pense que ce soulèvement
est inévitable si on veut éviter
un effondrement mais aujourd'hui tu vas
de très grandes banques françaises et
européennes qui sont virtuellement en
faillite c'est la mouche pays qui soit
mais c'est là où je voulais poser la
question est ce que tu penses pas que
l'état était si
prévenant et avenant avec l'âge et c'est
parce que c'est une grande banque et que
cette grande banque si par exemple elle
cookies et 25 lanceur dalet d' alerte
qui se réveille il suffit tu as fait que
tu peut-être gagnera l'intégralité de
son procès est ce que tu penses pas que
si une de nos grandes banques vacille
cela mettrait la france dans une
situation
internationale d'une façon
si délétère qui en couleurs est d'autant
plus vite parce que est ce qu'il ya
c'est pas un procès géopolitique cette
banque mais oui ça l'est mais je te
retourne une question si elle a mal agi
est ce que c'est parce qu'aller
grande respectable systémique qui aura
des conséquences que que qu'on doit lui
donner un blanc-seing et la laisser
filer ce que je vais te dire une chose
too big to fail ouais mais ça moi j'y
crois pas moi je crois pas crois pas à
ça moi je crois pas ça j'entends pas ce
propos il yad'autres jetons que c'est un
effet de levier de 90 c'est plus de 2000
milles moyenne à temps c'est pas on sait
pas où donner de la deutsche bank la
voix s'il ya des rigoles oui mais voilà
mais
on en a vu d on en a vu les plus grosses
mettre genou à terre
que la direction
écoute moi je suis impliqué dans un
certain nombre de dossiers en tant
qu'avocat ou
les jantes et dirigeants de banques
pointe du doigt un certain nombre de
traders en disant voilà les salopards
nous on s'occupe d'eux voulait brûler
médiatiquement maintenant brunel est
judiciairement et puis on perd à
l'amande que vous dirai pas ce que ça
c'est du fric ils s'en foutent mais vous
venez pas nous emmerder sur nos licences
de bancaire mais si je suis le
raisonnement pour société générale par
exemple qu'un groupe que je connais
particulièrement bien parce que ces gens
ont fait de nous des passionnés je pense
que c'est une erreur de leur part mais
ça qui s'est passé
société générale si jamais je décide de
la croira l'instant c'est à dire elle
n'a pas vu qu'un trader junior a engagé
sur le marché 50 milliards d'euros de
positions
elle n'a pas pu
l a pas vu que pendant toute l'année
2007 les activités
de son petit délinquant de trader
avait généré 26 milliards d'euros
d'entrées et de sorties de cash sur ses
comptes de dépôt de garantie
et complémenter par des appels de marges
tu sais poursuivre le les variations du
marché l a pas vu ça ça veut dire que
chez société générale tu peux sortir et
rentrer 26 milliards d'euros dans une
année sans que personne ne voie rien qui
est ce qu'il est mais système de
sécurité de ceux ci si c'est le cas mais
le système de sécurité de société
générale est imbattable d'ailleurs ils
étaient en train de le vendre dans un
roadshow européen
pour le licencié sous marque blanche
pour notre banque toi qui as pas depuis
pas de problème de sécurité saas et les
la parlotte tu voi e
pour dire on n'a pas vu mon préfère être
con coco complice et un truc tu vois
tu vois mais si tout ça est vrai si ils
ont raison alors ok on condamne kerviel
lorsqu'elle avait il faut le faire mais
il n'y a pas deux poids et deux mesures
si dans une institution bancaire dont tu
me dis qu'elle a un impact systémique
d'ailleurs c'est là une grande manière
de se défendre c'est à dire on est
tellement la société générale que s'il
nous arrivait quelque chose alors ils
ont plusieurs rideau alimentaire le
premier rideau c'est on a 160 mille
salariés qui vont partir au tapis etc il
s'agit pas de fermer société générale il
s'agit de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement français
fasse ce qu'il faut pour qu'elle arrête
de faire n'importe quoi
dans sa gestion du risque
ça ça devrait être la préoccupation du
politique moi ma préoccupation d'avocats
c'est qu'elle arrête de brûler des gens
parce que de temps en temps font sortir
du placard langat qu'on va aller
carbonisé au public pour ne pas avoir à
s'expliquer sur nos propres turpitudes
tu vois c'est comme ça qu'il faut la
chance mais si tout cela est vrai dans
ce cas là il n'y a pas une autorité des
marchés financiers
il n'y a pas la cpr ya rien de tout ça
ne me convient pas
donc là dans panama peppers par exemple
tu as vu dans la presse
perquisition
société générale
ou au luxembourg non non à paris ils
vont trouver quoi
c'est le truc est absurde tu vois bien
donc on fait des espèces de petits swing
et de petites goigs comme ça qui sont
des hochets médiatique pour te dire bon
voilà on a fait le job
et nous notre boulot que ce soit dans
panama papers où
je travaillais en tant qu'avocat pour un
des sénateurs devant lequel frédéric
oudéa a dit qu'il n'avait pas d'activité
directeur général général n'est pas
d'activité dans le pays de la liste
grise en ce qui concerne et société
générale pas au panama et puis on sait
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des activités des
activités multiples et florissante dans
cette zone géographique panama que ce
soit dans panama peppers ou dans kerviel
tu es dans un dispositif aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus fonctionner comme avant
a pas laissé filer ça donc moi mon
boulot parce que ce sont mes adversaires
parce que je trouve qu'ils sont en train
de d'abord salir l'image de la finance
par ailleurs prendre leurs actionnaires
pour des crétins parce que ce qu'ils
racontent
la vraie et puis ensuite tronqué le
cours de la justice
mon boulot c'est de te dire ça et de te
le dire jusqu'à ce que ça passe
et pour cela il faut politiser le
dossier donc c'est cette stratégie que
nous mettons en oeuvre pendant que veut
nous décrivent comme des gens turbulent
pas bien structuré
vraiment il faut par exemple que ce soit
en communiquant quand il parle de moi ce
sont des éléments de langage ans tu sais
ce que c'est les mêmes engage quand il
parle de moi ils ne parlent jamais de
moi comme d'un avocat il parle de moi
comme d'ordre comme communicants
parce que schopenhauer parce que si
jamais je suis comme unique en bas je
communique je suis avocat certes un peu
chiant alors moi je sais qui je suis je
pas ce que tu vois j'ai pas de problème
avec ça
on va terminer par une dernière question
comment tu vois la france dans cinq ans
[Musique]
je vois plusieurs
scénarii qui ce qui se chevauchent et
j'espère que je me trompe sur sur chacun
d'entre eux je pense très sincèrement
que s'il n'y a pas un éveil un réveil
collectif maintenant je pense que si on
ne va pas demander de comptes à nous à
nos dirigeants
et moi je suis d'accord pour que ça ne
se passe pas violemment violemment je
n'exige pas
que cette révolution soit nécessairement
violente sais pas c'est pas ça que
j'exige mais je pense que si on ne
l'aimé pas
en face des responsabilités
qui sont les leurs et s'ils ne se
mettent pas faire le job pour lequel ils
ont tous ces avantages totalement
exorbitant de la vie courante de
français parce que je sais pas si tu que
tu sais bien comment ces jours là vivent
quand il leur verbe mais c'est fou c'est
fou et quel que soit le bout par lequel
tu le prends quand tu vois 8000 euros de
coiffeur pour un gars comme françois
hollande par mois payés sur des fonds
publics tu te marres quand tu vois un
ministre qui rentre chez lui elle
travaille elle de flics se donne faim tu
te tu te marres
ce qui est rigolo si c'est quand tu vois
toi un ministre dans le cadre d'un
rendez-vous d'agrément amical et qui
débarque avec toute cette espèce de
l'entourage qui coûte de l'argent aux
français tu vois tu évoquais l'état
d'urgence tout à l'heure je ne me suis
pas documenté je sais pas combien ça
coûte et ça coûte forcément de l'argent
public pour un truc où on voit très bien
qu'on ne trouble de partout n'a pas de
sécurité dans les trains
tu vois quand tu prends un train pour
aller à londres bah on sait faire des
portiques comme dans les aéroports alors
au premier attentat j'espère ne pas
donner d'idées tu voir en disant ça ces
gens qui nous attaquent en france sur
notre sol mais au premier attentat qui
aura lieu dans un train tu vas avoir des
symposiums des bordels des congrès des
rapports des trucs des machins puis très
vite les trains seront sécurisées mais
personne ne croit que tout ça n'est pas
anticipable
donc je pense que si ces petites choses
là ne sont pas réglés de façon un peu
efficace et en fait tu vois conformément
à la lettre de la constitution française
pardon de venir homo et de la loi
française est un politique est là pour
représenter l'intérêt général rien
d'autre l'intérêt général si ça ne se
met pas à fonctionner comme ça je pense
que ces gens là vont avoir de
grosses difficultés à gérer ces
difficultés elles seront
des difficultés
populaire et il y à des discours
qui ont de plus en plus d'échos dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens
certains voient chez chez le pen une
solution à ça c'est pas mon cas certains
voient
chez mélenchon une révolte sincère ça ne
fait toujours pas voté mais je suis tout
à fait convaincu que la révolte de d'un
gars comme mélenchon et
tu vois et sincère certains se sont
détournés c'est mon cas de de l'acte de
voter alors tout le machin de c'est un
devoir citoyen et ses
fameux
sur quelqu'un comme moi ça n'a aucune
espèce de prise quand j'entends des
valses je crois que c'est pour les
régionales appelaient à un sursaut
républicain pour barrer la route à le
pen il ya un question il ya un moment où
il faut se poser la question de savoir
si la france ne mérite pas le pen c'est
pas un engagement à mettre au pouvoir ce
que je suis en train de faire c'est de
te dire que il ya tellement d'attentisme
chez nos concitoyens parce qu'on est
quand même un pays de gros cubes si on
se parle un peu directement tu vois on a
en a sept espèces de capacité à se
révolter
comme ça d'un coup à résister à à
s'agglomérer autour d'une cause etc mais
personne n'a vraiment réussi à modéliser
ce qui nous déclencher au plan collectif
et donc en attendant
enfin tu vois depuis montesquieu il ya
un peu de temps qui est
qui est passée qui a passé tu vois donc
je crois qu'il serait assez urgent de
se tourner vers des mouvements citoyens
le travail d'alexandre jardin par
exemple chez bleu blanc est bon je te
jette engagea à regarder ça de près
parce que c'est ce sont des gens qui
d'abord sont issus de la société civile
qui ne met pas des coups de klaxon
médiatique en disant regardez on fait ça
on est là pour faire la photo puis après
il faut plus rien c'est des gens qui ont
région dans les municipalités sur les
terres de france sont en train de
fabriquer des vraies solutions qui ne
sont pas des solutions politiques ils
font de la politique ils ne font que de
la politique mais
ils ne sont pas eux des hommes
politiques ce n'est ma voix ouais c'est
en pense
je pense que ça ressemble de très près à
ces schémas qui doivent être regardées
pour ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui et
espérer que ça deviendra
ce que les concepteurs de ma voix où
tout un tas d'autres mouvements doivent
avoir en tête quand il quand ils
s'unissent mais
il faut qu'on soit capable de bouger au
meutre maintenant voilà si je dois
stratégie à starcraft résumé alors je
sais pas ce qu'est starcraft en revanche
c'est sam écart d'âge qu'il va du jeu de
stratégie
en avant son but
je connais pas ça bon ok mais mais voilà
on est des français et nos dirigeants ne
devraient pas oublier qu'on a des
français parce que français c'est pas
je n'ai pas que les français nous il
faudrait pas que les français oublient
qu'ils soient français qui sont français
mais moi je suis d'accord avec toi j'ai
à te dire ça tu vois enfin c'est à dire
que je suis tout à fait conscient qu'on
est sur un média totalement alternatif
est d'ailleurs le temps que tu m'offres
n'existe nulle part ailleurs on n'aime
pas tomber dans le simple et court pour
nous tombé dans le simple et court c'est
le passeport pour le slogan idéologique
pure et on aime prendre le temps
d'écouter les gens n'ont pas cessé ses
choix
pour david koubbi merci salut à toi
c'est lui ni potes
[Musique]